[Music]
emerson is in chicago to start off this
hour hi emerson how are you
hey i'm doing great dave uh thanks for
taking my call sure what's
up so uh my wife and i were on baby
steps four five and six
we are a blended family with uh five
beautiful children the oldest getting
ready to go into her senior year of high
school
she just got her cna
and wishes to continue uh the nursing
path
and get her rn
here in uh
after her senior year my question is
kind of two part um
there's a local community college here
that offers has a great rn program
my wife and i have saved enough money to
send our
daughter through that
with cash debt free
however she has uh recently gone on
several college visits to
expensive universities
um and that would require her to go into
a significant amount of debt
so my i guess my question is how can i
create more buy-in for her to try and
lead her down the
debt-free path
and if we are unable to do so how would
you recommend we spend the money we
saved for her being that we intended to
keep her out of debt and not use it to
get her out of debt
so what is the conversation been like
when you say hey we've saved up enough
money for you to go to the school and
she says no i want to go to this
expensive school and you what's your
next question how are you going to pay
for it
yeah yeah absolutely how are you going
to pay for it and you know the student
loan thing
comes up all the time i feel like we've
kind of thrown our a
a lot of
we've used up all our dave ramsey uh
weaponry
to kind of clearly that's not working
just saying that well dave said it's got
to be on her terms and she's got to
understand the implications of the
weight of student loans which she has no
clue about right now has she been
working you said as a cna uh yeah
uh yeah well so she she just got her cna
a couple weeks ago um at the end when
she graduated uh so
you're you're a really nice man um
because i wouldn't have let my daughter
go on
tours of colleges
she lives in my house
you can't go test drive bentley's if you
can't afford a bentley
there's no reason to go on the lot no
reason to go on the lot
except get pissed off that you can't get
a bentley that's all that happens
and so yeah she certainly has you said
blended family is this your stepdaughter
no it's it's my daughter however she's
she lives mostly with her mother oh
so that's that's part of the uh the
battle here okay so her mother and you
you're not talking about your current
wife and you have saved up enough money
your ex and you
so so my current wife and i have saved
up the money oh your ex is not putting
any money in the equation
correct and yet she's stirring up the
pot
you got it
found the problem
not the kid
okay
i mean you can't you can tell it's not
about dave ramsey okay here's an idea
what about this do you have any good
friends that are rns that are like
40 years old or 50 years old
yes
have one of them take her to dinner and
knock her on the head
okay
and go i'm an rn and the dumbest thing
you could ever do is go pay money in
student loan debt for the college
experience when you can go get an rn for
free because your dad will pay for it
that's dumber than a rock have them tell
her that
okay she'll listen to a nurse right
that's what she wants to be because
here's the point she is not going into
debt to become an rn she's going into
debt to attend a freaking college that
she wants to go to she can be an rn
without debt we've established that so
really all she's borrowing money for is
beer pong
that's right that is correct this is
bullcrap i mean they got a good call
they got a good football team which you
don't play on darling
okay
i mean
you can attend the game over there for a
lot cheaper than you can attend the
college over there
we talk about this in the bard future
documentary which i would recommend you
sit down and watch with her and have a
conversation about it afterwards 88
minutes it will definitely change the
way she sees the entire college i'll
give you a free list we'll give you a
free link to watch borrowed future
together and we'll send you a copy of
debt free degree
but here's what you're going to have to
do is there any chance you get to talk
to your ex in a reasonable tone and she
actually catches on to the idea that
this has to stop and she needs to quit
this
no i've tried that um i i sent her uh
a long text message and uh with used uh
soft gloves so to speak and uh kind of
just a little bit of where she's coming
from i you know she she she thinks you
know that uh because some places offer
free parking and free laundry
that
that uh that's worth um
going into that going into in ending so
i missed the part where it's free
exactly yeah that's dumber than a rock
oh my god wow okay yeah yeah well i
don't know if you're going to
counterbalance your ex-wife's stupidity
it's going to be difficult but i think
if you get a good rn to take your
daughter to dinner and knock her on the
noggin and tell her that she does not
need to do this it's a dumb idea go be
an rn and then you can have some
experiences
and you because you'll be making a lot
of money and you don't have to go to
that other college to do that number one
number two we'll give you a link to uh
hang on uh also pick up we'll give you a
link to borrowed future watch that with
your daughter the next time she's there
lock her in the room with you
don't say anything let her talk when the
movie's over believe me george and i and
the gang in borrowed future will do our
jobs it is uh it will scare the bejesus
out of you on student loan debt when you
watch this thing it is the student loan
program is an epic failure
but here's the thing oh you asked me one
other question i didn't answer
if you don't do what i want you to do
that i think is wise and good for you
because i love you i will give you no
money i will not fund your stupidity
partially
i will not participate financially in
your crazy butt decisions
this is dave talking to his kids
this is exactly what it sounded like at
our house
no
is a complete sentence
no
it's dumb and i'm not gonna participate
in my daughter who i love being dumb and
crazy and i'm not gonna fund it now
you're going to be nicer than that
because you are a nice guy
i'm just that dad
so hang on alliston will pick up we'll
get you the book
and the documentary and
uh yeah you look done riled them up man
the landscaping the football team the
water slide the ex-wife the lazy river
the whole thing it's got the whole story
here this is the ramsey show